die situation ist noch lange nicht unter
kontrolle was uns im
robert-koch-institut große sorgen macht
sind die besorgniserregenden noch
ansteckender und varianten des virus
aktuell sind es drei besorgniserregende
varianten die wir im blick haben
die variante b 11 7 vj 13 51 und b 1 1
281 alle drei varianten wurden in
deutschland bereits nachgewiesen wir
haben jetzt einen ersten überblick wie
häufig die varianten zur zeit in unserem
land vorkommen
besonders die variante b 1 1 7 das ist
jene variante die erstmals in
großbritannien nachgewiesen wurde
im moment ist es die von den drei
besorgniserregenden varianten am
weitesten in deutschland verbreitete
diese variante ist ansteckender als die
bisherigen und es gibt auch erste
hinweise dass sie auch vermehrt zu
schweren verläufen führen kann
um einen überblick zu bekommen haben wir
verschiedene daten benutzt und
ausgewertet da ist zum einen das
ergebnis einer ad hoc erhebung in
laboren von letzter woche darin wurden
rund 31.000 positives auf zwei proben
mit einem speziellen pcr test auf die
varianten nachuntersucht
außerdem haben wir die genomsequenz
daten ausgewertet und zu dem auch die
meldedaten der gesundheitsämter w 11 7
ist bislang in 13 bundesländern
nachgewiesen worden
das ist der stand von anfang der woche
und diese variante die 117 macht ihn zur
zeit in deutschland einen anteil von
etwas weniger als sechs prozent aus wie
117 wurde in den letzten wochen auch
immer häufiger nachgewiesen was bedeutet
dass aus unserer sicht
erstens die drei varianten vor allem bei
117 sind in deutschland angekommen
zweitens sie dominieren das geschehen
noch nicht aber wir müssen damit rechnen
dass sich der anteil weiter erhöht
ähnlich wie es auch in anderen
europäischen ländern
berichtet wurde in den letzten wochen
der bericht zu den varianten den finden
sie jetzt auf den webseiten des robert
koch- institut unter www.rki.de
wir müssen also damit rechnen dass sich
vor allem bei 117 weiterverbreitet und
dass die pandemie bekämpfung dadurch
erschwert wird
diese variante ist ansteckender und saß
cause 2 ist also insgesamt gefährlicher
geworden
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir alle
maßnahmen weiter konsequent umsetzen um
ansteckungen zu verhindern
wir müssen die ausbeuten von sauerstoff
und auch der varianten zumindest
verlangsamen und wir müssen verhindern
dass neue varianten entstehen natürlich
behalten wir alle diese varianten im
blick meine damen und herren
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren